- Can I whiff the shirts?
- Like does it smell
like weed?
- [David] I guess
this could.
- He's whiffing right now.
(upbeat music)
- [Host] We brought
together seven high people.
- I'm high.
- It's safe to say I'm kind of high.
- [Host] Two of them are sober.
If the group discovers who the moles are
they'll split a cash prize.
(upbeat music)
If the moles survive,
they win the entire prize.
Who are the Odd Ones Out?
- [Louie] Let's start off with a snack.
- [Stella] Yeah, can I cop a cookie?
(group agreeing)
- [Sean] Just gotta break the ice.
- [Stella] Cheers.
- You're not gonna?
- I don't eat many sweets.
What's your guys' favorite, like munchies
or what's your go to
drink or whatever?
- I will eat anything
that is in front of me.
- Chips and salsa just-
- [David] Oh, true.
- Always hits.
- And guac.
- Dude. This sounds weird,
but like cold weenies with hot sauce.
- Nah.
- Don't knock it,
don't knock it until you can try it.
- Do you boil the weenies or microwave?
- Um, I think-
- Nah, I've tried it.
- They're already precooked.
- It's not good for us.
- They're precooked.
- Do you just like take
'em out the package?
- Yeah. I just like raw dog 'em.
- You raw dog the dogs?
- Oh, shit.
- [Louie] Yeah.
- Going hot on the glizzies.
- Dell Taco.
- Glizzy. Yes.
- I be drinking gallons
of juice when I'm smoking.
I drink a lot of juice I don't know why.
- What kind of juice?
- Apple juice, orange juice,
any kind of juice, you
know that good (beep).
- So you're healthy, right?
You don't, you're not
eating sweets and you're-
- I mean, I like sugar, but you know
I don't go for like this
kind of stuff, you know?
- I was mostly suspicious of Dimitri.
He was like taking charge a lot
and he also didn't eat any of
the snacks, which was weird.
Cause there were chocolate donuts.
Like you're gonna eat those, right?
- Wait, am I picking up an accent?
- Yeah. I'm from Australia.
- Do Koalas get stoned over there?
- What?
- [Louie] From eucalyptus?
- Yeah. Weed isn't legal there yet though.
Everyone smokes, but like-
- Probably shouldn't go there.
- He said it was illegal over there.
So that kind of meant like,
okay maybe he didn't have access to weed,
but obviously we're in California
so he for sure has access to weed.
I really have no clue to be fair.
Wait!
Actually, go ahead buddy.
- No, you go.
- I don't want to be rude.
- Okay, I was just gonna say
yeah let's get into some questions about,
let's try to figure some (beep) out.
- How did everyone like
get high before this?
- Smoke? My go-to I
smoke a blunt, you know.
- A blunt.
- A spliff.
I was in a session making music.
That's what I do for a living and-
- Oh nice.
- Me and my buddies shared a few spliffs.
It was nice.
- [David] I hotboxed my car,
for like two hours before this.
- [Sean] Hell yeah, hell yeah.
- Hotboxed my boyfriend's car.
Cuz I can't drive.
- Did you guys do that
before coming here today or?
- Yeah.
- Can I whiff the shirts?
- Does it smell like weed?
- I guess.
- [Jade] You can try.
- [David] I changed right before,
but this could.
- He's whiffin' right now.
(Louie sniffing)
- Do I smell bad?
- I smell (bleep) over here.
- I'm not gonna lie.
All of my clothes smell like
weed because I just smoke
in my room and that's
where my clothes are so.
- I knew that Dimitri was high
from the second I stood next to him.
The smell was, I believe the term is dank.
(Cade laughs)
- I'm sure everybody can
relate on this one though.
Like, do you guys get like super stoned
where you feel like, if you have animals,
you're like, "oh (beep) dude,
you're gonna die one day."
And then you're really sad.
You get super sad.
- No yeah.
- I feel like they know-
- Might be projecting.
- every single time that I'm high.
- Really?
- They act freaking weird.
Yeah, they stare at me and they're like
you got high again.
(clock ticking)
- I learned nothing.
(bell rings)
(everyone laughs)
(upbeat music)
(buzzer sounds)
- Oh that's messed up man.
- Thank you.
Honestly, I was pretty
shocked when I was kicked out.
You know, I know that I smell like weed.
- I don't know, I thought it was obvious
that he was the mole but I could be wrong.
(footstool clatters)
Oh my gosh.
I'm sorry.
- [Host] How good is everyone's balance?
- I mean, we're chillin' dude.
We're not, like I said, we're not drunk.
We're stoned.
- He's been practicing.
- We're stoned.
- [Stella] And backwards?
I do not think I could-
- Come on like.
- Ooh.
- Okay.
- I wanna try it backwards now.
- Oh my god.
- Ooo okay.
- She like walked backwards
and then walked even more.
- Just like this.
Just like this, just like this.
And I'll do a little two-step in front.
(group cheers)
- [David] Oh man.
- Okay.
- Let's see if we can-
- [Stella] Oh, watch out.
- [David] My bad.
- The walking thing didn't
really help me decide
who was high or who wasn't high.
- Dream blunt rotation.
- What?
- It's like
who you would want to smoke weed with?
- Check this out.
- Go ahead.
- On 420, and this video's coming out,
and I played on a song
with Snoop Dog and Doggface. The guy-
- [David] Oh yeah, the skateboard guy?
I like him.
- The cranberry juice guy
and Cheech and Chong.
So I got to smoke a jay with him.
Not in the video,
but like after.
- That's sick.
That's really awesome.
- Dude, that's dope.
- I already got to do it.
- You already got it.
- You living it.
- What the heck?
He was giving youth pastor vibes,
but like he doesn't smoke,
but he's been around people that smoke.
Snoop Dogg.
Joe Rogan. Seth Rogen.
- Yeah that's like-
- Oh Joe Rogan,
that's a good one.
- Joe Rogan'd be dope.
- I don't know about that.
- Hey dude, he's bald, man.
- I don't know what that has to do-
- Everybody wants to
smoke with a baldy once.
(bell rings)
- She was like really coherent.
(upbeat music)
- I feel like he just seemed
like a little trickster.
- [Host] We have a tie.
(group gasping)
The tie is between Sean
and David.
You guys are gonna give 30 seconds.
State your case.
- I am so baked.
Smoked outta my bong at home.
Had a little dab pen here.
- Did you name your bong?
What's your bong's name?
- It's just a vase.
(buzzer chimes)
- Everybody knows you name your bong.
- I personally always name my bongs.
Even after a break, may
they all rest in pieces.
- I hotboxed my car for like
two hours right before this.
We were planning on doing it for an hour,
but then we got home two hours
before and we just stayed
in the car.
(buzzer chimes)
(upbeat music)
(buzzer sounds)
- We're sorry.
- It's all love.
- Yeah, take it for the road.
- Sesh after, sesh after.
- I didn't have a name for my bong.
Comment down below what you
think I should name my bong.
Cuz I have no idea.
- [Host] Raise your hand
if you think the mole is still in the box
and you would like to continue the game.
Starting now, for every
time you vote someone out
who is not the mole, the total
prize money will be reduced.
- Here's my thing.
I feel like the thing was like,
are you high or are you sober?
It's not if you're
stoner or if you're not.
- Yeah exactly.
- Because like you could
be a stoner in here
and not be high.
- True.
- So I feel we should guide away from like
what's your favorite high story
and things like that.
Just because I feel like
some of you guys are not acting as high
as some of us.
- Also, it hits different.
Cuz I know some people-
- That is true!
- that always say
"Oh dude, I just get in my head."
- I have this couch in
the middle of my apartment
and I literally last night
ran around it a couple times.
- Because you were high?
- Yeah.
- All right (beep).
How old is everyone?
We could do that.
What if someone's underage?
- 25.
- 24.
- 22.
- I'm 20.
- [Stella] 20. Mmm?
- I have my med card.
I have my med card.
(group laughing)
- Damn.
Now look, you screwed him over.
- I have a bad back.
I got in a car accident in 2017
and I've had back pain,
lower back pain, ever since then.
So I got my med card.
It was pretty bad.
I had to wear like a neck brace
and I got chip in my hip.
That rhymes.
(sirens yelling)
- David, better grab your med card.
- He was straight.
He had the card and then like
the cops were after him too.
Like we heard the alarm.
We got actually worried for
David for a second, but yeah.
- All right.
Favorite strains?
- [Louie] Oh that's good.
- See, I literally only do edibles.
So like just Sativa, Indica or Hybrid
is all I really know.
And dab pens.
Like the vizzy I think, I don't know.
- Yeah Stiizy.
- Stiizy, Stiizy, yeah.
- What's your favorite Stiizy?
- That's a good one!
- I don't know I don't know!
My friend bought one and
I just had the rest of it
but I really just do edibles.
I promise guys, no!
(group laughing)
- Whoa there, pal.
- I feel like people know strains
even that they don't smoke it.
Pineapple Express is a movie.
Do you least know how to make them?
- Huh? Edibles.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
- Okay. Perfect.
- With a cheese cloth and everything.
- Yeah.
- Yes, I know how
to make them.
(bell rings)
(upbeat music)
(buzzer sounds)
- Aww sorry.
- I'm sorry Stella.
- Guys!
- [Host] Raise your hand
if you think the mole is still in the box
and would like to continue the game.
- I don't know.
How much money is gonna go away?
- Can you give us 30 seconds
to like think about it or like 10 seconds?
- [Host] I will give you,
literally put 10 seconds on the board.
- Okay, 10 seconds.
- 10 seconds, okay.
- I have no clue.
- I dunno bro.
- Oh my god.
Do you guys wanna vote
or it's up to you guys.
- I'm just going with
whoever wants to stay in.
I don't know. I'm stuck dude.
- [Host] If you think the
mole is still in the box
and you'd like to continue
playing, raise your hand.
- I don't know.
- I feel like you're good.
It's the med card bro.
It's the med card.
- All right yeah, we'll go for it.
We'll have one more round.
- Here, wait, wait, wait, wait
I have this thing from
a cart in my pocket.
- Oh like the cap.
- It's the thing
that goes on the top of the cart.
It's in my pocket.
- Hmm.
- Wait.
I feel like you kind of threw
yourself away on that one
because my brother smokes nic.
And that's what the tip
of the flue looks like.
- I don't even know
what a flue is.
- I don't smoke nic.
- That's like a vape.
- Yeah, but this is from weed.
- Okay, did you get one earlier?
- Yeah.
- What was the shape of your
weed pen that they gave you?
- A cylinder, like the rest of them.
- Wait, let me see the cap.
- [Jade] I love this detective-ness.
- Oh okay, nah he's straight.
- What kind of wraps do you guys use?
- [Cade] Oh, Raw.
- Yeah I just do pre-rolls honestly.
I'm too lazy to-
- Well, same
Same.
- Or like the cones.
I was trying to come up with scenarios,
because I felt like the
mole was still in there.
I came up with that her
boyfriend was just a stoner,
and she was just getting
all that from her boyfriend.
- [Louie] Should we all
just say our bong names?
- [David] We could, yeah. We could.
- Bong Marley.
(group laughs)
- He came up with Bong Marley.
Like what the (bleep)?
I didn't mean a curse, but
too trying to be a stoner
Might as well name it,
Snoop Bong.
Mine's Dory.
- [David] Dory?
- Cuz she's blue as hell.
And it reminds me of Dory.
- Mine's named Sunshine.
Cause I like to wake
up with some Sunshine.
- My name's Ex Wife.
It's been passed
down from my friend.
He gave it to me.
- That's legit.
That's how I got Dory.
- Cuz he graduated from high school
and he handed it down to me
and he's like, "here you go."
(bell rings)
- I'm going to need
one of these for.
- [Cade] Treat yourself.
- Louie, can you show us?
- Oh my bad.
- Just hold it.
(upbeat music)
(buzzer sounds)
- Thanks guys.
Appreciate it.
- I think we're good.
Like we're chill.
- [Host] Raise your hand
if you think the mole
is still in the box and you
would like to continue the game.
- I'm gonna let my guard down.
I'm gonna have trust issues if we lose it.
- For real.
- I already have trust issues.
They'll get worse.
- [Host] So if the lights turn green,
that means you have voted
the mole out and you all win.
If the lights turn red,
that means the mole is still
in the box and you lose.
- [All] Nooo.
- I was thinking green,
you know, for weed.
And then it turned red.
- [Host] Will the moles
reveal themselves in three,
two,
one.
- Nooo.
- Oh my god.
(group laughing)
- My story's real,
it is actually from my mom and everything.
I just took a break for my mental health
to actually work on it
without the weed, you know?
- Yeah, I smoked one time
and it was a horrible experience,
had to get medicated and all this.
Like it was more than
just paranoia, whatever.
Just like wasn't good for me.
But it's been a part of my identity
that people think I'm high all the time.
- Hashtag.
Never trust Cade.
- [Host] Any other thoughts?
- Not really.
I'm just really high.
(stella laughing)
I'm sorry.
- Oh, lets go.
(Cade laughing)
Let's see how I'm gonna
count it real fast.
Just figure out how much I got here.
Can pay rent.
Say no to some gigs.
I'll buy you guys some weed.
How about that?